my all-time favorite shepherd's pie
what's the secret
behind a really good
shepherd's pie
i would think the vegetables you use and
growing in it
so we're going to use leeks and onions
and they'll start browning off the mints
you know no color no flavor i've never
forgotten that you know that yep
so
good to have color gotta have color
otherwise it puts that grey tinge on the
shepherd's pie that looks greasy and
cheap and nasty
they don't want that julie and i know
you don't do cheap or nasty let me clear
your peelings now huh all right thank
you very much there's no nails in there
now is there no
don't be cheeky
i remember
your
amazing shepherd's pie
and that lovely little restaurant used
to work in sheep street in stratford
so you never got food sent back
no sometimes they complained that there
were
you never ever got a complaint no
how long have you worked at that
restaurant for
six shoes six years
oh hello chilly
what are you cooking i'm gonna make okay
i sort of modern version of nanny's
shepherd's pie dad shouldn't manny be
doing the cooking because she's the
better cook excuse me right mum would
you would you top our uh our onion
please daddy yeah oh gosh your eyes are
gonna water
in there we've got a delicious steamed
treacle and date pudding let's just
separate it for you
um how do skeletons call their friends
how do skeletons call their phone i'm
not too sure on the scalabone i'm just
gonna tilly come on
okay so two cats are in a race one is
called one two three and the other is
called
under 12. who
won depends who's the fastest cat one
two three because under 12 cats sank
[Music]
oh goodness
tells why do you make a nice cup of tea
for nanny you want me to disappear
thank you
bye so give that a little fry off okay
mm-hmm
nice
quarter these jokes they get worse
oh she's only having a bit of fun
sauce worcester sauce that's gonna give
that really nice spicy seasoning
oh thank you
okay yeah
tomato puree in
you could put a ton of tomatoes in this
if you want you could yeah
put that mince back in there once it's
drained
i'm just going to put a little touch
i know you'll go crazy at this a little
touch of red wine
really
why the red wine well because i'm going
to make it nice and rich
okay
produce the red wine down yeah and then
start covering your
with your stock
now i'm gonna bring that up to the bowl
okay and then get some fresh rosemary
okay
like it'll taste yes please
is it hot it's a little bit hot be
careful
as it cooks out the wine and the alcohol
will disappear it'll be delicious trust
me
now good spring onions we'll chop up
and that's going to go through
the mashed potatoes it's going to sit on
top of that nicer i like that savory
yeah delicious mince that's laced with
all that red wine nice so sprinkles into
there please mum
and i'm going to drain off the potatoes
hi there hello hello
oh hi jack hi hi hello hello jack have a
nice day school yeah
yeah
so we'll dry out those potatoes and then
mash them
no oh can i mash them would you okay um
holly slice a little knob of butter in
there for jack please
so what was the restaurant you worked
out there were you a chef
cook
i love the diplomacy were you a chef i
was a cookie exactly that
not really
you used to help me as little
right you kids do
no potatoes
these are nice and fluffy are they
aren't they and do you want mom look
delicious mashed potatoes yeah with no
lumps in there
hey weren't you getting it
huh
it's great having you back in the
kitchen mommy now yeah seriously brings
back good memories
no
just
why'd you do that dad i just wanted to
fork it to get it nice and spiky
so i want that nice crispy topping
and then lightly grate that cheddar
cheese on top and that goes in the oven
literally 20 minutes 180 minutes jack
can you on the door please
that looks lovely doesn't it
even though you said you didn't like it
earlier okay
back in the day mama's meals all came
with two veg and this is no different
but with a modern twist
braised peas and carrots with a
fantastic homemade mint butter
shepherd's pie
glazed on top that looks lovely doesn't
it
and then the carrots
that's why i didn't put carrots in let's
put them on the side i'll see
last job before serving pour that
gorgeous butterscotch sauce over the
pudding
okay i'll take one at a time
that smells incredible
this is my ultimate childhood dinner
shepherd's pie with crispy cheese champ
topping sweet buttery peas and carrots
that is the rib eye we've had that in
the fridge not wrapped so it sort of
almost air dries and it intensifies the
flavor gross so much quicker and there's
less water in the beef
for me the only downside to perfect
roast dinner is the fight about who
washes up afterwards
so meg and i are going to avoid that by
cooking everything in one roasting tin
starting with the spinach and mushroom
stuffing
[Music]
a little bit of salt and pepper please
here we go
some of your left shoulder left shoulder
thank you
in with the garlic and the mushrooms to
toss the pan you push down and pull back
down and push back off you go take your
time
push it down and flip back good that's
it push down
nice that was lovely and again
nice oh i'm gonna drop let's see well
done well done well then right we're
gonna sort of make a little well a
little touch of butter in the middle
now we need to start putting the spinach
in the middle please
so you can push that down spinach is
cold so you're not gonna burn yourself
be confident in the pan
toss it and you'll see it wilting
and disintegrating away wow who would
have thought all that spinach could fit
in this pan because it's a very delicate
leaf it sort of cooks so quickly put
this all on your board now
and then i just want you to go
and give that
a nice chop then when you're confident
with one hand
we need to pick up the other knife the
other hand
chop it nicely good
now outside and come in gently
good
regroup
and take your time
good
mmm right
i love that smell what is that lemon
thyme lemon tan that's right so you get
your little thyme stalks and you pour
down you sort of strip
lemon thyme in now tarragon taste
brilliant with the beef fantastic with
chicken and fish roughly chop the
tarragon when i sprinkle the fresh
breadcrumbs so the breadcrumbs almost
sort of bring the stuffing together
next we're gonna get an egg yolk
now with the beef this is the exciting
part
slice
with the bone and then come inside and
go two thirds of the way down
hold that open for daddy salt
and pepper
and then look we pack our stuffing in
there
this is amazing it's incredible now just
gently hold that there like that
okay
yeah i'll see you tomorrow what
tying string around the rib will keep it
all together during roasting not too
tight if we tie it too tightly what
happens the stuffing will come out
that's right
that's ready for roasting but we're
gonna protect it and sit it on a trivet
so trivet basically is almost like a
sort of little little bed a little bed
that's right
if you want to enjoy these delicious
roast vegetables at their best make sure
you remove them from the hot oven after
35 minutes and reheat before serving
with your beef
a little mix for the top a couple of
teaspoons of mustard powder in salt
a couple of tablespoons of olive oil mix
that in
i'm gonna pour my mustard powder over
the beef so this forms a really nice
glaze
my one pot roast dinner goes into a hot
oven 15 minutes at 230 degrees then down
to 170 degrees for another two hours
for a delicious twist on traditional
yorkshire puds i'm going to lace mine
with fresh horseradish
[Music]
start with plain white flour in a bowl
and crack in the eggs
adding only half of your milk at this
stage makes it much easier to whisk all
the lumps out
and if like me you like your puddings a
little lighter and crispier add a
dribble of cold water and add salt to
season
when you're happy your batter is lump
free whisk in the remaining milk
peel and grate horseradish
and add a handful to the mix
we can leave the batter to rest while we
get the meat from the oven
that is beautiful and this is where you
really need to let it rest how long
would you say to rest it for um i like
to rest the meat for at least 20 minutes
just the right amount of time for us to
whack up the oven and to get our
yorkshire puddings in
i love using the rich dripping but
vegetable all is a healthier option
to get the fluffiest yorkshires your
tray and fat must be piping hot
for best results take your jug of batter
to the oven and pour the mixture in
there
it takes just 15 minutes for our
yorkshire puds to puff themselves up and
turn a delicious golden brown that up
place that onto the board
parsnips parrots you can see why we kept
them in half they've got all that flavor
one beautiful big slice
for daddy
one for maggie
and then from the side the stuffing the
stuffing the bit that's the best to die
for
now fantastic yorkshire they're amazing
aren't they beautiful mm-hmm
that's for you my daddy
on that one that's for me
beautiful roast beef
with a twist wow
[Music]
i go fishing a lot and scotch eggs are
the perfect all-in-one mini picnic
breakfast first thing get your eggs
cooked bring the water up the boil onto
the spoon
and lower them into the water that way
they don't hit the water and crack four
and a half minutes that'll keep the
center nice
and slightly runny
now
ground sausage meat i'm gonna make mine
a little bit spicier i'm gonna crumble
in black pudding that helps to season
the scotch eggs inside a little touch of
salt and pepper
and then just to make it a little bit
sweeter and a lot easier for the kids to
eat some grated apple
[Music]
combine that blend in the apple and the
black pudding
eggs once they're cooked drain them and
then run them under cold water
cracking and cooling the eggs quickly
will prevent the yolks turning gray
tap them on the side of the pan
put them back into the water and what
happens the water seeps underneath the
shell
see the shelf come off so much easier
eggs still slightly soft in the center i
want that little bit of richness with
the yolk
next you need to get yourself organized
with a mini assembly line
seasoned flour
a little egg wash
and breadcrumbs
take
your mince golf ball size
spread the pate manipulate with your
thumb
and then
sit your egg in there
and spread
the sausage over the egg
and you just seal that over it's really
important to keep that nice even coating
of sausage meat around the egg you don't
want it too thick otherwise it gets too
dense and it's unappetizing
give them a light dusting in the
seasoned flour
if you don't put the flour on the egg
wash won't stick and if you don't put
the egg wash on the breadcrumbs won't
stick
into the egg
roll it round
shake off
any excess egg wash and roll it into
your breadcrumbs you can use this same
three-stage method to breadcrumb
anything you like from chicken guzons
and fish fillets to fina schnitzel
these are panko breadcrumbs japanese
white breadcrumb so no crust
you can experiment by adding flavours to
your breadcrumbs like parmesan herbs or
citrus zest
i always like to push the actual
breadcrumbs into the sausage meat so it
gets that really nice golden brown and
stops any of the outside burning
once breadcrumbed lower the eggs
carefully into a four centimetre deep
bath of hot vegetable oil for 10 to 12
minutes
the eggs are actually cooked
soft and running the center so the
objective is just to cook the sausage
meat and the black pudding
looks great don't they go and grenades
there's something so magical about a
scotch egg on a picnic because it's like
this little mini breakfast
beautiful
drain them onto the paper roll them
round just to get off any excess oil and
then to transport them
some greaseproof paper
that for me is the perfect start to the
fishing trip it's no wonder i never
catch any fish because i'm always too
busy eating my scotch eggs
[Music]
my ultimate black pudding lace scotch
eggs an irresistibly delicious picnic
breakfast
you